in boston's chinatown michelle wu a
child of taiwanese immigrants made the
case for a greener more inclusive city
this is about the future of boston and
making sure that we are meeting the
moment with
bold fearless leadership that includes
every single one of our families every
single one of our communities her
opponent is also a first generation
american anissa acai b george is the
daughter of immigrants from tunisia and
poland and like wu she's a democrat who
served on the city council i'm going to
vote for michelle
i think she has a great platform she has
really great interest in the community
and she's backed by really
admirable and like people in
in like
higher up congress to support hers i
think michelle who probably has
a more open mind when it comes to policy
making and i don't know if that's
because she has just a tiny bit less
experience in the political machinery
this city known as the birthplace of the
american revolution hasn't elected a
republican to run it in almost 100 years
and it's never elected a woman or a
person of color no matter which
candidate wins the mayor's race marks an
historic first for boston but it also
represents divisions in the democratic
party both here and nationwide
the city has a long history of racial
tension and one-quarter of its
population is african-american
there were three black candidates on the
primary ballot but none made it into
tuesday's runoff a fact that's led to
recriminations among some boston
democrats over the course of this
campaign i've made a few promises that
i'm able to keep this work is too
important to simply do behind a podium
at city hall it has to be done in
community woo has the support of senator
elizabeth warren and others from the
most liberal wing of the party but she's
also caught the attention of some
special interest groups who've been
spending money to defeat her her victory
would be interpreted as part of that
that movement and the question is
whether these traditional interests are
going to fight back
against what they might perceive as a
two progressive agenda on things like
climate and transportation and
development etc still democrats can't
lose in a race that shows how
dramatically the city has changed
kristen salumi al jazeera boston